Baby, baby, baby.
Tip of the tip of the tip of the teat.
My marvelous mother makes me minchi on
Monday [clears throat].
You sleep here?
What? The penthouse was booked up.
Nah. Way too much space up there.
Nice bidet, though.
Like taking a shotgun up the ass?
No, no, I sleep here because it reminds
me of where I was before Vegas.
Back then, I lived with a real solid
group of dudes.
But then the world took a shit and I
came to Sin City.
Now, that was a party.
You've been here alone for over two
decades.
Oh, shit. Has it been that long?
Look at this guy. Hasn't aged a day.
What a beauty.
No, I'm not alone.
I got Harold. Which have you?
You haven't met Harold. Here, I'm going
to introduce you. This is Harold, been
my best friend since I was a kid.
You know, my entire life, people have
been lying to me. Even my f***ing
parents. But never Harold.
No, you can't lie to me.
He can't lie anyone.
I can see that.
I don't know what I'd do without him.
Look at that smile. So you got a
Harold?
No, I got an Evelyn.
Oh, that's cute.
Look, before I met her, being alone was
all I knew. Now she makes everything
easier, you know?
Sometimes I wish I could make her
laugh. Right?
I have to say, after all this time,
that's the sound I miss the most.
You know what sound I miss the most?
Sound of hand me clapping together.
Nothing like that. Glorious applause.
I mean, it's almost better than hearing
somebody choking on their own blood.
But look at me getting carried away.
Good thing that your Evelyn's got
hands, huh? She must clap for you all
the time.
No, she doesn't. She's my car.
You talk to your car?
That's weird, man.
Oh. Oh, there you are.
So if Evelyn's not the girl.
Who's she? I got this little pest
crawling through my vents.
See I was gonna starve her, watching
the life slowly drain from their eyes.
Kind of my artistic process.
You know, the last guy lasted almost
four weeks.
Hey, Wilbur. I think she's going to
give you a run for your money.
She won't. Oh, bloody baby, baby, baby.
Hey.
You tried to kill me every chance you
get. Why should I show you mercy?
God damn it.
Hey, man, why don't you let her out?
And why would I do that?
No, no, no. Listen. What good is an
audience of one? Think about all the
meat slapping you hear with four hands.
That's true.
It don't often get feedback from the 18
to 35 female demographic.
Fine. You fish her out and take a seat.
Don't worry. I got a table just for
you.
And what happens after the show?
Well, you go on your merry way.
Really?
Well, if I'm being honest, nobody
survived all three acts.
Curd your loins.
Curtains up in ten minutes.